good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday hope everyone's
having a great day thus far I am because
I'm sitting down with my one true love
[Music]
I just made that up hey Ben how are you
doing yeah it's not a song it's not a
song that was fantastic because you are
my one true love
I'm doing excellent happy Monday to you
all may this week be blessed may this
week be blessed you're looking sharp bro
College dressing up for the toaster you
have important businessman Tings after
this I have some important stuff today
but really this outfit was of course for
the toast right it's a very special you
know podcast that you're on it is I just
want to share that I know that
everybody's gonna get angry for my shoe
because the last time I was on I'm so
glad everybody was upset at my shoe and
I just want you all to know that I need
to cross my legs if you were in this
studio you'd understand that it was
built for the Seven Dwarves and uh I'm
not one of them and these things are
really low and if I go like this it
hurts my back so I need to have this
elevated no one was gonna say anything
with Snow White
I won't say it actually what I'm just
gonna ask if she used this studio before
you guys moved in but I didn't deliver
it in time no you didn't you didn't I
didn't um thanks for being here Ben
thank you darling we had a lovely
weekend that I did that I would love to
share it started out for me kind of like
on a low because I got stuck in an
elevator on Friday night yes do tell
well I really honestly don't want to
relive the trauma but let me just say
this
I was stuck in an elevator for about 25
minutes
I was stuck with Theo and a lot of
people were like well at least you had
Theo and to be honest being in there
with Theo made me very anxious what is
the airflow situation in an elevator the
second I realized that I was stuck I
started to get hot I'm like oh my God I
felt like I was in a hot car but I don't
know if that was just Plessy but like my
mind playing tricks on me or if it was
actually hot because then I was just
getting worried about Theo who's
standing there in a fur coat worried
that he's getting hot then the person
who was helping me was like you should
sit down it's gonna be a while and I was
like [__] me and I had limited phone
battery which is so not like me but it
was the end of the day I hadn't been
home yet you know it was a busy day and
we were stuck there for about 25 minutes
I was wanted to like make content and
stuff I thought you know if I'm gonna
get stuck in this elevator I might as
well go viral on Tick Tock but I had no
phone battery so I was trying to really
conserve what if I needed to call the
fire department you know so all in all
25 minutes being stuck in an elevator it
could have been way worse could have
been like three hours but I haven't been
stuck in an elevator and maybe since
high school I was stuck in an elevator
remember like five months ago for what
probably an hour no mine was in 25
minutes no it was wasn't an hour but it
was more than 25 minutes yeah it's
terrible it's so scary I mean I was
stuck on the ground floor so if the
elevator you know everyone's worst
nightmares the elevator just drops and
starts free-falling I really wouldn't I
wouldn't have died I would have just
went down one floor but when you were
stuck in the elevator what floor were
you on 15. they do claim though that
that is a complete myth that you can
just fall and drop to your death
I feel like I've heard stories I mean
everyone in New York remembers that
story it's possible though that the mid
25th and third that woman was literally
walking out of the elevator and the
elevator dropped and she got sliced in
half
I oh I think about that every time I
walk out of an elevator hmm
so I don't think it's a myth because it
happened
not to scare everyone I read afterwards
because I did a lot of research right
that it's not possible and I'm just
gonna stick with the fact that it's not
possible sure and maybe that elevator
was like from a different age of
elevators
you know maybe
I don't know no I really do understand
why there are people who have like
phobias of elevators who will literally
walk 50 floors before they get into an
elevator but the thing is for me like I
understand the fear but I could never
take the stairs so
it's not going to be a phobia for me I'm
scared of stairs have you heard of that
do you know where that Shabbos elevator
is the one that I'm talking about that
never stops yes okay let's get into that
so for those who are maybe confused a
Shabbos elevator is an elevator so
basically on you know the Jewish sabbath
if you're of a certain level of religion
incredibly religious you can't use
electronics and you can't you can't use
an elevator because it's electric and
it's a machine and it has like a whole
thing it's electric
but there is one elevator in the world
that on Shabbos doesn't stop it rolls
very slowly with the doors open down
every floor so that when you get to your
floor you can just like kind of hop off
it's insane I mean it's actually like
not that scary it's not going fast I've
seen video it's not going that slow yeah
where is it I don't know it's like this
world famous Shabbos elevator yeah I
don't know Prague it's somewhere
International for sure oh that for sure
but I think I think it's in Prague yeah
because when the elevator stops that's
what makes it like
not Shabbos approved you know oh we
can't stop right
it's so dumb no that's why like why I
seriously like well we'll never be able
to be that religious come on that's
crazy
um so my weekend was not off to a great
start with the elevator Saga but you
were in Boston I was I went to see the
Bostons and they showed up showed out
everybody was amazing did you get out of
the car and say I think a good Boston no
I actually got out of the car and said
what the [__] I was in five and a half
hours of traffic and I should have flown
Boston is like low-key so far Boston is
so
difficult to get to because you're
filled with regret no matter either way
what you choose no I think a safe bet
and I told you this is always in the
train yeah but then you're sitting on a
train
an Amtrak they got the snack cart you
know I just don't find trains glamorous
but you love to just like sit and roll
calls and like pop off emails and like
that's what you do on a train they have
really decent Wi-Fi yeah everybody says
that until you don't have it you just
like you're an anti-train and I think
you're wrong like you literally have
never taken a train you're sitting here
saying I'm anti-trading the last time I
went to Boston we took the Acela you did
with me no I wasn't for my show yeah I
was I didn't take the train oh no for
the last time I went to Boston was for
that meet and greet and we drove but we
took the train remember I woke you up at
six in the morning because I couldn't
sleep and I'm like let's just go home
and we got on the train yes see it was
nice no I don't remember trains always
run on time I don't remember being nice
I just feel like you're being negative I
also I have one bone to pick it's not
with anybody in Boston it's more with
the people that have rest stops in
Boston nothing's open after 10 p.m the
highway rest stops I I went from it
honestly it was three states I went from
Massachusetts to Rhode Island to
Connecticut I couldn't find one I was
just looking for a sub Rhode Island I
feel like that's like not on the way no
I think we're in Rhode Island I think so
no I feel like that's definitely wrong
what do I know honestly I know less
about geography than you so interesting
I just feel like Rhode Island is like
not like near should I start calling you
out no no I'm just I'm just
pondering geography just pondering
geography you know when you were stuck
in the elevator telling that story you
called yourself Alicia I didn't stop you
I lit what
you'll see wait on the toast yep
on you this episode I called myself
Alicia wait what are you doing wait what
are you talking about you'll see what
was I saying you were saying that uh
people were saying that Alicia and Theo
were stuck in the elevator uh no okay at
least
no I didn't call myself Alicia you sure
I'm positive I was like that was weird
called me out because I would have
called because I would have called you
back out for this here I didn't want to
I didn't know that we're in a world of
calling people out we're not in the
world of calling people up but we hold
each other accountable here on the toes
so you're telling me I didn't go through
Rhode Island uh no I'm saying I don't
Rhode Island is south of Massachusetts
is it not I feel like it's north no that
I know for sure I know for sure that
it's South for sure
Massachusetts Rhode Island regardless if
I was in three states or two
I think you would have had to go through
like New Jersey Delaware no I was at a
minimum in Massachusetts in Connecticut
okay and I can say that there is not one
open Subway terrible Jersey Mike's Jimmy
John's anything if you're looking for a
late night sub after a long day you
can't get it no that's criminal you
can't get it that's reason enough to
never go to Boston so then I had to go
to freaking McDonald's which I gotta
tell you I love McDonald's no it just it
just doesn't make me feel good oh your
belly it hurts yeah
I don't even remember what'd you have I
don't even remember then you remember
remember and you don't want to tell me I
didn't I don't even remember I know that
you know I remember now this is a grimy
gross it's fine I didn't have anything I
won't be I won't Ben okay Ben is tell me
and then we'll tell everyone why no
it was just it was gross what did you
eat chicken nuggets or a chicken
sandwich I had this chicken sandwich was
disgusting so Ben doesn't eat out kosher
meat no sorry it doesn't eat nothing he
tries Ben tries not to eat non-kosher
meat I struggle everyone knows but
sometimes you come to tell me but
sometimes you come to a group no you're
too judgmental sometimes you have a
literary complex where you're like
you're judging me I'm like no I'm not
you are I would have understood late
night long day McDonald's who
understands better than me no but and I
didn't even want it like I'm here eating
and I'm looking on the menu there's no
MC plant which by the way make plants
might as well be make Cancers and like
honestly yeah I don't subscribe to it I
agree they also don't have filet of
fishes which by the way that can't be
sustainable fishing I don't think that
God wanted me to eat this unsustainably
caught fillet of fish 100 he'd rather
the chicken that God knows what that is
it's not even chicken that can't be
chicken well honestly down with
McDonald's you can tell me anything okay
thanks I can't believe I just caught you
in that and you didn't really catch me
it was more of like a I think I really
caught you I think there's more cat and
mouse well in a cat and mouse the mouse
gets caught which is what I did to you
it was more of like uh what's that like
is that cat and mouse what I don't know
where like each one knows where they're
just like playing the game I don't know
you know what I'm saying maybe cats I
think it's Cat and Mouse
um okay so how was the Boston mean
unbelievable unbelievable probably like
150 showed up we were at the urban grape
lovely lovely liquor store
pictures honestly this one was really
fun like we we had like long
conversations got to know everyone there
was it was like a real Spirit Society
tasting and it was really really fun
good then I drove back wanted to kill
myself got back at two in the morning
I'm like you keep saying that I was
literally awake you got back at 105. but
okay I got back at 1 30. no no it's
still late it's 105 but like no need to
make it like more dramatic no no it was
no
late and you worked it was not 105. it
wasn't it was I mean I was up reading my
book for book club which was so bad
maybe it was 120.
I know because I dropped Robert at 107.
no you didn't and he's on 78th and Lex
you didn't I was literally up I was
tracking you like to find my iPhone I
was so tired waiting for you but
whatever such a pain in the ass no no I
mean I'm telling you that's when I got
home you're gonna say like I keep
calling you out but maybe if you stop
lying no no that's when I got home sure
we wake up
Saturday
we hung out with the kids Olivia's in
town we saw Kayla oh true Kayla cookies
true and Levi was such a nice day he
fell asleep on uncle's nipple yeah it
was so cute he did and then we hit the
club Saturday night I got a massage in
between oh you did that's so Ben and I
finished my book for book club which
really plagued me this week if you ever
come across a book called before you
knew My Name by Jacqueline lovelitz just
run as far as you can like I cannot
stress how this is probably one of the
worst books I've read like in my career
as a reader it was so bad what's your
last name Jacqueline lovelitz lublitz
she sounds Jewish
um but then we went to the Nick game
yesterday we did and can you explain to
everyone the significance of what's
going on with the Knicks in the NBA
because it's crazy right
it's just crazy because the Knicks like
are so bad and this year they're so good
and like the team is like we we got a
real shot yeah we got a real shot and
it's not like you guys have any like
it's not like LeBron's on the team you
know it's just like some good peeps no
we signed this guy named Jalen Brunson
and he has brought the house yeah it is
no it's brought the house down brought
the fire yeah uh and the garden was just
electric they gave everyone light up
bracelets it was giving Taylor Swift
Eros to our energy honestly and every
time like something good happened all
the lights went off it was pretty sick
it was it was unbelievable by the way
probably very distracting if you're
playing for sure having those lights for
sure but the Knicks are now up 3-1 in
the series yep it's best of seven which
means that you need to win four to
advance and this man over here courtesy
of Michael Cohen Harper and Scott shout
out will be in Cleveland Wednesday night
for the Clincher for the Clincher okay
like if you go and they lose it's like
so your fault yeah but then I'll be here
for game six Friday night if that
happens but I'm just saying watch the
game on Wednesday I'll be behind the
Knicks bench so people can like take
pictures yeah yeah
um and if they make it to the next round
of the playoffs when was the last time
the Knicks made it past the first round
of the playoffs a really really long
time
I think it was Carmelo Anthony and you
have been a Knicks fan like your whole
life and they've really always been just
like a really terrible team how does it
feel do you feel different that they're
good they're decent no because they're
still not like gonna wait like no but
it's still exciting no it is exciting
but it would be nice if I don't know
maybe this team is good enough we'll see
yeah we'll see because it's really by
committee which is
just exciting it's not all on
I guess it really is a lot of it's on
Jalen brunch yeah a lot of it but he
scored all the points he did he did
Julius Randle didn't play even a minute
in the fourth your guy yeah do they know
that story yeah I told the story when I
literally made up that I knew Julius
Randle just because I felt like lying
about something yeah it's funny that you
call me a liar at least I own that I'm a
liar afterwards no no yeah cause it's
called a pro
the program
it's called the prime it's called a
prank
um and then yesterday we watched
literally the greatest show of all time
we did Ted lasso like should win I get
that it wins Awards but like give it a
better reward what awards does it win
they win like Emmys and stuff like that
nobody [__] about the Emmys they need to
win a Nobel Peace Prize they do it's the
best show the writing the characters the
story lines the everything it's amazing
they somehow deal with mental health and
soccer all at once it's also criminal
that they're dropping episodes like one
at a time it's so [__] annoying we
waited as long as we could and then this
weekend we binged all seven and it
wasn't enough no it wasn't enough it's
so annoying like just drop the [__]
season but I just want to say one thing
I'm not here for a spoiler alert if you
haven't seen this season yet I'm so not
here for Kiley moving on like we need
her and Roy to get back together yeah
yeah true like what's going on bro I
can't Roy can't work and Roark and Troy
and try again but
who wouldn't be his hair is just like my
dad's no it is and it's kind of cool
that's why the writing is so good it's
like he's a beloved character and his
character's Arc you know working for the
independent really would have written
him out of the show but they brought him
back so cool like they listened to the
fans they're like they love Trent Crim
and I actually have a story today that's
kind of like a real-life Ted lasso Story
coming true tell me I will it's about
Ryan Reynolds okay
well I guess we could yeah we could dive
in long enough Okay cool so uh you want
to do it yeah now you can do it without
further ad do that do that do here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know and today's episode is brought to
you by Caraway get a head start on
spring cleaning with Caraway their
thoughtfully designed sets and
complementary storage makes getting and
staying organized easier than ever you
can now save 10 on the full Suite of
Caraway products from their internet
famous cookware to their newly launched
food storage set caraway's Heights
quality ceramic coated kitchenware as
free is free of PTFE such as Teflon lead
cadmium and other toxic materials
caraway's kitchenware comes in variety
of chic Shades and they all include
complementary easy access storage
solutions Ceramics naturally slick
surface means minimal oil or butter for
slide off the pan eggs and easy cleaning
so if you live with another human being
who makes eggs and sandwiches on pans
and then never puts them in the sink God
forbid the dishwasher you can live
peacefully knowing that okay once you
get to it in a few hours it won't be
stuck on mess because it's the Caraway
easy slick surface and Ben can leave his
cheesy eggs in the pan for as long as he
wants
how did you even turn an ad into a diss
track it's not a diss track that's what
I live with and that's why Caraway is
such a blessing my God great and what I
live with is somebody not ever using a
Caraway God forbid I get a home-cooked
meal wow they're non-toxic products are
made with out any toxic materials it's
easy combing with their ceramic
naturally slick surface and they are
well loved over 40 000 people have raved
about Caraway kitchenware so visit
carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
10 off your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com toast10 or just use code
toast10 that's toast10 at checkout
Caraway non-toxic cookware made Modern
today's episode is also brought to you
by betterhelp so uh better help as
everybody knows is super important when
getting to know yourself because it can
be a lifelong process especially because
as human beings we are all growing and
changing grow when we do it every day
we're growing in the evening and even
when we play therapy is all about
deepening your self-awareness and your
understanding because sometimes we don't
know what we want or why we react the
way that we do until we talk through
things and better help connect you with
a licensed therapist who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery wherever
you are so if you're thinking of
starting therapy why don't you give
better help a try it's done entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule you
just fill out a brief questionnaire and
you'll get a match with a licensed
therapist and you can switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge so
anyone who's done therapy knows that
like a kind of a rite of passage is
meeting with one or two or three
therapists before you find like really
the right match for you and a lot of
that can be really awkward because so
much about like being in person with
strangers can be so awkward but better
Hub is done entirely online that means
everything you do is done right from
your phone or your computer you can
video chat you can phone call you can
text you can do all of the things you
can video I mean you can just regular
phone call
um and if you want to switch up
therapists it's super easy and it's not
awkward and better help understands that
that's just a part of the process so if
you want to discover your potential do
so with better help visit betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
toast thank you better help for
sponsoring today's episode are you ready
for the past five stories Ben I am this
one's about your doppelganger everyone's
talking about it we'll talk about it
inside Sophia Richie and Elliot grange's
lavish wedding in France so Sophia
Richie's loved ones are still raving
over her lavish wedding weekend in
France this weekend the stylish
socialite 24 tied the knot to Elliot
Grange in France on Saturday with her
older sister Nicole Richie taking
Instagram taking to Instagram one day
later to gush Over The Newlywed so we
have gotten like a lot of content over
the course of the weekend but in terms
of the actual wedding we haven't seen
much yet Nicole Richie posted a photo we
had seen this like Vogue thing about her
Chanel made her dress there were a bunch
of stars there Paris Hilton of course
her sister Nicole Richie Cameron Diaz
you know Benji and Joel Madden do you
know them yes so Nicole Richie is
married
to Benji Madden or Joel I can't remember
which one and then Cameron Diaz is
married to the other brother so it's
kind of like a rocker Affair do you
think they what band are they Benji and
Jill Simple Plan yes no no no Simple
Plan what band are they oh God I'm being
exposed oh you're not a real fan I don't
even remember okay hold on let me just
Google it really quickly you don't know
Benji what I think it's no it's just
morning brain it's uh
Good Charlotte oh I don't think I knew
that I did okay I did do you think there
was a good Charlotte performance at the
wedding that's pretty sick I mean I hope
there was a Lionel Richie performance
that's what I was asking first cheating
he needs Good Charlotte when you have
hello is it well he did walk her down
the aisle we have a picture can you
imagine he doesn't appear to have a
microphone in his hand and I do feel
like that would take away from like you
know oh my God what a dream imagine he's
holding your hand walking to you down
the aisle with a mic singing hello is it
me you're looking for
I can see it in your eyes I can see it
in your smile what's your favorite song
oh it's gorgeous I told you that the
music video is about a blonde girl yes
you did it's hello it's me you're
looking for and she's like I can't see
you no that's really not cool
um well in terms of Music obviously uh
Lionel Richie Benji and Joel Madden but
also so why Elliott Grange like got
Sofia Richie is he's very much like a
nepo baby his dad is the chairman of
Universal Music Group the chairman of
the board cool so they have a lot of
connects you know yeah who do you think
pays for the wedding when two people are
so rich it's like Lionel for sure
Lionel's like a stand-up traditionally I
mean Lionel just whips out the checkbook
and says hello
okay so everyone thinks you look like
Elliot Grange and you you're not happy
about it it's not that I'm not happy
about it
I do see it and I think he's I think
Elliot Grange is extremely handsome
there's nothing wrong with it
looks like a nice guy
handsome guy
saying the two people that have the same
glasses look like each other it's just
not a good comparison yeah people look
like each other when you take off their
glasses right and you actually look at
their face yeah right yeah not just oh
somebody else has rounded frames right
they look like each other well
interesting to note that he did wear his
glasses on his wedding day did you
I feel like you took your glasses off I
think I think I did I think I did but I
think you wore them the rest of the
night
I'm not sure I remember in like some
pictures I know that I wore them yes I I
remember some pictures having them yeah
well also he's he's Jewish and she
converted and they had like a Jewish
wedding he's wearing yamaka look she's
doing the wine thing they have a rabbi
it's nice wow love it people are
obsessed with this wedding like people
who didn't really think like of Sophia
Richie a lot this wedding has really
turned her into like a much bigger star
because I think people are really
impressed that she's just so classy
everything she's doing so elegant south
of France Chanel Couture three looks
from Chanel the style the grace the
Elegance
um and she was sharing the whole thing
on social media which was really fun
until the actual wedding like we've
gotten nothing I'm sure she has a Vogue
wedding exclusive which is why we don't
have any photos yet and that's why I'm
sure Vogue weddings will post it
probably today
um but like let's go like I need to see
pics like what happened inside it's just
like so cool that Elliot gets to have
Lionel Richie as a father-in-law you're
just obsessed with Lionel Richie I I'm
obsessed I've been obsessed for a very
long time I love wine could you name one
other song besides hello no
so you're not like that big of a fan no
but like that song has a special place
it's so good
um okay well I will just continue to eat
up every piece of information that is
being brought to us out about this
wedding like I
I'm obsessed like I just I feel like I
would love to know how many followers
Sophia Richie got on Instagram this
weekend because everyone was following
her wedding and she just joined Tick
Tock the wedding the weekend of her
wedding to you know make some content
let's see how many followers she has how
many do you think she has everyone's
talking about this wedding and while you
do that I feel bad that I don't know
more of Lionel's catalog and I just want
to make sure that she has half a million
followers she has half a million powers
on Tick Tock she just joined Tick Tock
which is pretty impressive I'll tell you
more Lionel songs ready okay cool yeah
Lionel Richie so of course oh
I knew I missed something
all night long
um
My Endless Love You know that one maybe
um stuck on you I don't know that one do
you no but I probably do he's really
he's a groovy guy he's unbelievable he's
transcended you know many different
generations and he's kind of a legend
legend
hello I literally knew you were gonna
say that um so again I hope we get more
more content on this wedding more Lionel
Shore
um did we get any Lionel there is uh you
know the paparazzi there were vultures
circling the hotel du cap Eden Rock and
um there are Paparazzi pictures of them
leaving yeah he walked her down the
aisle there's poppy Paparazzi picture of
her and Elliot kissing I think they were
posing for some photos and then
Paparazzi pictures of Cameron Diaz
arriving
um Paris Hilton arriving but there
really isn't we didn't get any actual
wedding photos
well I wish them well I wish them well
too and I just I need more content
um okay our next story I wanted I know
you don't know about it and I didn't
want you to read up on it because I
wanted to get your reaction it is the
cutest story and it's a real life Ted
lasso come to life so Ryan Reynolds and
his business partner Rob mceleney
mceleny
their soccer team has been promoted to
the English football league so Ryan
Reynolds and Rob scored a huge goal over
the weekend when their Welsh soccer team
secured a promotion to the English
football league so the move occurred
Saturday when the Hollywood Duo's
wrexham association football club moved
up to the English football league for
the first time in more than a decade so
basically Ryan Reynolds and this guy Rob
bought this Welsh soccer team it really
is giving like AFC Richmond vibes from
Ted lasso they weren't very good and
they kind of gave them the Hollywood
treatment they did a um documentary on
them it was on FX that was really
popular they made like social accounts
they were like about going viral on Tick
Tock and
I think they also like put money into
the team and got good players and
whatever and over the weekend they won a
game that officially secured them up
into the next League like they got
promoted and oh my God the people in in
Wells whales oh my God that was so
embarrassing the people in Wales stormed
the field they were crying like people
have loved this team it's been like
their local team and they've never made
it and Ryan Reynolds and his friend Rob
got him there and Ryan Reynolds took to
Instagram to say everything I own smells
like champagne beer and grass I'm still
I'm still somewhere between giggling and
sobbing this town in this sport is one
of the most romantic things on earth
thank you at rexham AFC and it's just
like very exciting and it's a real it
feels like Ted lasso
everything Ryan Reynolds touches turns
to Gold that mobile company Mobile just
sold for a billion dollars 1.4 crazy
well so prior to their promotion this
weekend the club was fifth in the
English football division and rexim has
been relegated outside of the top four
leagues since 2008 after 87 straight
years of competing in the football
league it's kind of cool and I've never
really thought about it until they
started talking about it on Ted last so
now you brought it up the idea that in
soccer you can like not stay in the NBA
right like if you're bad enough go to
the G League the whole team well that
yeah right that happens in the states
like with players like you can get
promote you can get demoted to the
D-League if you're syncing it up you go
back to the miners I like you said the
states the states
um yeah and I didn't know that was a
thing until I started watching Ted last
so that like the team has to be good
enough to stay the league and you know
they're probably Blitz a fire under
everyone's ass it's much cooler that
it's the whole team Yeah because
sometimes you like send individual
players down because they stink but
really team sport
teams not just that team yeah if a team
member a team wins the whole team wins
if a team fails the whole team fails
exactly yeah pretty cool it's pretty
cool and by the way I guess I didn't
even realize like Ryan Reynolds like
really is killing it not even as an
actor killing it everywhere yeah
Aviation gin oh Aviation gin yes mobile
the soccer team soccer team he's always
in a commercial or something
Blake Lively's uh Betty Buzz yeah I
don't think that's like a huge um I
think for them they started she started
a uh what is it it's like a mixer right
a cocktail mixer it's cool it's like a
competition to Fever Tree what's that
the most popular like gin and tonic like
got it uh Seltzer I'm a Schweppes yeah
but it's different yeah it's not
actually that different it's not that
different but like these are they're
like creative whatever I'm just saying I
don't think that's like on the level of
all the other projects that they do but
yes just killing it that's killing it
how much money do you think he has a lot
a lot and he's also an actor and he does
like Deadpool and you know all those
things yeah he's a lot that's so crazy
he's also I I found out recently that he
owns his own production company yeah
because those commercials are amazing
witch hunter Falls all of them for
Aviation Gin from It Mobile he just like
has this shtick that's actually very Ted
lassoy even in the shtick well that's
also like when you get to a certain
level of celebrity like every project
you do all the companies that you use
for that project like production company
you then just own yeah like um I
remember from when I watched Kevin
Hart's documentary a lot of the movies
he makes are produced and I like
conceptualized by his own production and
like creative house or whatever yeah
well really smart killing it killing it
that's a cool story which the soccer
thing right yeah I know it's like giving
head last one honestly like the video of
like everyone storming the field like
you know it could bring a a tear to the
eye bring it here shred a tear
um so congrats Ryan and Rob moving on to
our next story going from some
celebratory news you know good news for
the whale the Welsh some bad news for
anyone who loves a good Bed Bath and
Beyond Bed Bath Beyond has filed for
bankruptcy after failed turnaround
efforts so on Sunday bed Beth Beyond
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection after it failed in several
last-ditch efforts to raise enough money
to keep the company alive the beleagued
Home Goods Home Goods retailer has been
warning of a potential bankruptcy since
early January when it issued a going
concern notice that it may not have the
cash to cover expenses after a dismal
holiday season so shares of the company
closed at 29 cents on Friday giving it a
market value of 130 million dollars the
stock is down about 88 percent since
last year and last April it was trade
trading around twenty dollars a share so
now it's 29 cents that's really abysmal
on the company's namesake stores and 120
Buy Buy Baby locations will remain open
for the time being as it begins to close
the business and liquidate assets it has
filed motions in New Jersey Bankruptcy
Court asking permission to auction the
two Brands the company said in a release
it has already committed to closing all
of the harman face value stores man
I just I just think somebody will buy it
this is devastating because I don't know
what the relationship is like for people
who don't live in New York to Bed Bath
and Beyond but for New Yorkers like Bed
Bath and Beyond is a huge
huge thing for us was I don't know the
last time you were in a Bed Bath and
Beyond but this like attempt to fix it
completely ruined the stores what do you
mean Bed Bath and Beyond if you've been
in recently like turned into this like
attempt to like I won't say that it was
bougie like everything in there was
expensive it was like so they're really
like a Walmart competitor they lost
their way what is it they lost their
brand I mean I don't know what this
means for Lori Grenier yeah I don't know
that's like her thing on Shark Tank is
like I can get you in bed to Bed Bath
and Beyond I do think that after you
said
that their stock is 29 cents and their
value is 130 million somebody should buy
that and just turn around those stores
the thing is when I was thinking about
like oh how could they go to business
it's like a necessity for so many people
they really never crushed the online
game
I I have no idea like they their website
stinks yeah they're um honestly a huge
opportunity for someone to go in buy it
make it what it was right like so many
of these like big box stores started
offering like you know curbside pickup
same-day delivery like Bed Bath Beyond
like never really innovated in terms of
like ordering online I've actually I'm I
love Bed Bath and Beyond and I go like
when I need stuff I've never ordered
from Bed Bath and Beyond online they
need like a partnership with like Amazon
or something and they really could have
like you know amped up their game in
terms of um wedding registries you know
they just kind of stunk up the joint
yeah
and I can't tell you how disappointed I
was when I went in recently why because
it was just like it was just like like
almost like Fine China like it was just
such like a weird it's really the store
you go to on two occasions before every
summer for Camp because you needed
shampoo conditioner Q-tips comforters
egg crates all the necessities and when
you move into a new apartment because
what do you need when you move into a
new apartment shampoo conditioner Q-tips
egg crate mattress pad college dorms
there's like no it really was with me in
every stage of my life it was a great
store and I will say like the last time
I went to bed Bethany on was probably
the last time I moved which we've been
in our apartment for four years and we
probably did a big Bed Bath and Beyond
you know new bowls things like that when
we moved actually remember your mom took
us it was a great store I know I'm sad
I'm not sad because it'll be back you
think you don't think this is the end no
I think that they have a really really
strong brand name and somebody should
buy it and make it better and I didn't
realize they owned bye bye baby and what
I know is being you know a sister to two
moms they buy babies like a huge huge
store like it has everything that a new
mom or a mom could need it's like you
you know you stop you go to Bed Bath and
Beyond before your college dorm and then
you go to Buy Buy Baby before your first
baby really the brand is with us at
every stage of Life goodbye for now it's
not a goodbye it's a see you later see
you later I I was shocked to hear that
honestly I only wasn't because I feel
like I don't know why I thought that
they already filed for bankruptcy I know
I feel like these big box and like these
big brands use chapter 11 bankruptcy as
like a means to get out of debt yeah and
they never actually go away like hasn't
I heart media gone back yes 250 times
such a good call but it's just like
always fine yes data money oh but we're
still throwing Jingle Ball right like
what the hell is it you're so right no
so it's like a tactic it's like a
business thing people do so I never know
like when somebody files for bankruptcy
if it actually means like their store is
gone forever I don't think Toys are Us
yeah I don't think so right yeah they're
still a business I think so there's like
a few yeah
um before we dive in let me tell you
that our next couple of stories are
brought to you by the farmer's dog when
you look at bags of dog food you see
pictures of bright carrots and juicy
steaks but when you open the bag all you
get is burnt smelly pellets well dog
food needs some fresh thinking eating
processed food for every meal isn't
healthy we all know that and kibble is
subject to multiple rounds of high heat
processing making it making it Ultra
processed food so try something fresh
try the farmer's dog so the farmer's dog
is fresh food it's delicious food your
dog will love it it is made in human
grade kitchens it preserves the
nutritional value of the whole meat and
veggies that go into it it is real fresh
healthy food there are so many benefits
to switching over to a fresh healthy
food like farmer's dog for Theo it was a
great change in his breath his coat was
really shiny he had lots of energy on
their vet developed recipes are
delivered uh straight to your door and
they are personalized for your little
fella for as little as two dollars a day
the meals are arrive in pre-portioned
ready to serve packs they're
conveniently delivered on your schedule
and dog people across the country have
ordered millions of meals from the
farmer's dog it has never been easier to
invest in your dog's health with fresh
food so get 50 off your first box of
fresh healthy food at the farmersdog.com
toast plus you get free shipping when
you go to the farmersdog.com toast
that's the farmersdog.com toast to get
that 50 off your first box and free
shipping thank you to Farmer's dog for
sponsoring today's episode today's
episode is also brought to you by Legacy
box with Mother's Day quickly
approaching it is a great time to get
Legacy box for the whole family so
Legacy box you are going to love it is
the safest and easiest way to digitize
memories on analog media that you don't
have a way to watch anymore so relive
moments like wedding days First Steps
Mitzvahs both bar and Bot
um reconnect with your family's history
and hear your grandmother's voice again
for the first time with Legacy box so
Legacy box is changing the game aim for
families in America send in your legacy
box filled with your old VHS tapes
camcorder tapes old pictures and their
team will professionally digitize
everything by hand right here in the USA
you'll get back a thumb drive or the
cloud along with your originals and it's
so simple it basically works like magic
we did it it was actually
not to take credit for everything my
idea
um we very much grew up in the VHS era
we had so many vhs's just like piled up
in our storage unit we had no idea how
to access them until Legacy boxes then
we got it back and we all just spent the
day watching these old videos of like
you know grandparents dad us singing the
Spice Girls it was really so sweet and
it's like such a shame that technology
works in the way that it does because so
many people just let those memories die
but Legacy box does not for a limited
time go to legacybox.com toast for their
best Mother's Day sale ever buy today
take advantage of that 60 off of a
legacy box and send it in when you're
ready so it's legacybox.com
toastlegacybox.com t-o-a-s-t for that 60
off your legacy box
okay ready for a little sports news uh
that we somehow missed yesterday at the
Nick game Pete Davidson gets handsy in a
fight with a Knicks fan at Madison
Square Garden I didn't see it I was
watching them the whole time we saw Pete
Davidson but this happened outside of
the Arena outside of the the actual
core like you know back inside like by
the food where did it happen I can't
what am I trying to say like not in the
room with the court
in the arena in the arena but not on the
got it Pete Davidson was going to get a
hot dog something like that rhyme some
fan tried to grab his junk he punched
him in the face Pete Davidson let a
fellow Nick's fan know to keep his hands
to himself while the former Saturday
Night Live star stopped to take photos
with fans after attending the New York
basketball teams game at Madison Square
Garden on Sunday one man got a little
too close prompting Davidson to take
action so the video was posted to social
media of the interaction shows that the
unnamed man who was dressed in a pink
polo and a Nick's hat put his arm around
the king of Staten Island actor who was
taking a selfie with a different fan
Davidson then shoved the man and
exchanged words with him before resuming
taking photos with other less handsy
people he threw up a peace sign while
posing with one woman after the
aggressive interaction and his reps
didn't immediately return page six's
request for comment
um I have to say I saw the video and I
definitely feel like people get really
handsy with celebrities and they like
invade their privacy and kind of have
like no regard for their private or just
personal space um but Pete Davidson was
like in this mob taking pictures with
everyone touching other people this guy
put his arm around him I didn't really
feel like what this guy did was so crazy
just felt like this particular guy
pissed Pete Davidson off do you have the
video I do dude I would just like to see
it sure okay take a look
oh [__] hold on and if you want to watch
it it's on page six I'll put it in the
description of today's podcast okay
okay thank you page six for literally
the worst video that doesn't work
um and I need to see it Jesus [__] come
on
Let me refresh okay now you're making me
do this okay okay man technical
difficulties please stand by you guys
now by the way it's not your technical
difficulty it's page six
okay down with the news let's try this
again okay
you see that yeah go again
I don't know how
and then he resumes taking pictures I
don't know how
I don't know how
okay I'm looking
okay it's perfect no I can't figure this
out this iPad is gonna be the death of
me it's gonna put me in an early Rave
okay there we go
ready yep set
[__] you you sound like Roy again oh
[__] you okay ready
I got it ready it's the guy in the pink
shirt
he really wasn't like doing anything he
looks like he might have whispered
something yeah like which is gross and
creepy like put your mouth in near
someone's ear
but um I feel like Pete Davidson is kind
of just like in his angry era you know
he literally drove a car into a
residential home in Beverly Hills with
his girlfriend yeah no I like Pete all
right but are you taking Pete's side in
this yeah people in New York are just
like oh honestly that guy looked like a
massive tool he just looked also maybe
like he was drunk can we still use the
word tool yeah okay cool maybe he was
like sweaty and like spitting on on p no
like you just got to see the guy like
yeah he looks like just a mess he looks
like a guy you want to punch in the face
but it was star-studded at the Knicks
game last year it was Timothy chalamet
Lily James Pete Davidson Ben Stiller and
his wife Sienna Miller been Soffer and
his wife then sopher and his wife so
many you know Hall of Fame athletes
Victor Cruz John Stark who else John
Starks Starks uh who else was there
Tracy Morgan Bernard King Tracy Morgan
Spike Lee it was really like packed it
was packed that's the best part of going
to Nick games such a good game it was I
had a good time yeah I had a great time
even though we didn't eat no we didn't
it was like weird time we're like we're
like we'll eat at home I had a hot
pretzel I'm not gonna lie but like I
didn't have chicken nuggets or anything
no also like the lines were just too
much the lines were and honestly we
couldn't order any food like the the
person came in like the third quarter I
don't want a chicken sandwich in the
third no we were also like sitting in
the middle of the row so it's like we'd
have to scream over 10 people like hey
can I get like a Hershey bar it's like
embarrassing do you want to talk about
the smelliest man on the planet let's
talk about the smelliest man on the
planet who was sitting next to next
house at the at the game Claudia has
this thing where we go to games and she
always has she's always right the guy
next to her oh man spreading like
sitting on my lap always puts his leg
like in her chair because she I sit with
I sat with my legs crossed that doesn't
mean that like the space that I'm not
using then belongs to you like my
negative space is not your positive
space [__] back the [__] off but she
loves to complain about it to me but
when I say let's switch seats let's do
something about it let's tell the smelly
ass man to move his [__] leg
and he was sitting on my vagina like it
was so it was so next level like not
self-aware we did switch seats by the
way because then Ben oh you're gonna man
spread all right Ben you man spread you
go shove your knee and it like I like I
wasn't gonna sit like with my legs wide
open it barely got better by the way he
was so smelly he was really smelly and
this is just like a PSA like if you
don't wear deodorant don't go out in
public yeah you don't have to wear
deodorant no and if maybe
if maybe it's about a week start working
so maybe you shouldn't leave your house
for that week just honestly just don't
go out in public or or honestly you can
go out in public but be outside don't go
inside yeah like it's just not nice to
everybody else and again I'm not
advocating for deodorant do what you
want no and I want to don't sit next to
me I know that there are people out
there who actually have like illnesses
that like you know that make them smell
and I'm very sympathetic to that and I
know I could tell by this man's smell it
wasn't that no he just didn't wear
deodorant he was like Dutch too I know
what you're I know what you're talking
it was Dutch it was giving like European
Bo and if you know there's a difference
you know and it was so rancid like my
eyes were burning yeah
Dutch
we don't know that he was dead oh he was
asked me by the way he was judge no by
the way you were about to say he wasn't
speaking English doesn't mean he's Dutch
no but he was blonde and he was he was
he was Dutch all right he could have
been Dutch he was like stoop waffle you
know maybe it's German actually all I
know is that he was smelly yeah you know
German BL and to your point German bio
is lethal answer your point
smelly not sick smelly no not sick
smelly I'm sympathetic I know people who
have like diseases where they smell like
I am okay with that you know what like
of course you do you bro but like if
you're just poor in your hygiene I'm
sorry you should like wear like
something though if you do have that
sickness I know I know but it smells
different that's the thing this was just
like smelly man smelly armpit hot
t-shirt
boiling hot
it was hot yeah disgusting he was and
and by the way so they kept giving you
know it's a playoff game so it's high
stakes they gave everyone towels and
you're supposed to like you know you're
supposed to whip around the towel like
you know to cause drama in the stadium
so I'm under this man's Wing because I'm
short and he's whipping his [__]
towel and spreading his seed all over
the stadium and it was not right heinous
and I think we need to start you know
calling people out who smell I wanted to
you wouldn't let me I know well honestly
the smell wasn't bothering me because to
a certain point like you can't really
help that you smell like maybe you
forgot to put on deodorant and it's hot
like at some point you can't make
yourself stop smelling I'm sympathetic
no if it's too late you know I smelled
like that and I caught a whiff of myself
smelling keep your arms down I would
either keep my arms down or I would
leave temporarily go to Dwayne Reed get
or like just go to the bathroom like put
some soap and water under your arms I'd
buy a new t-shirt but that's what I
would do but with the bo thing I mean
sorry no with the man spreading thing
it's like you are actively doing this
you are actively at attacking me so like
I really wanted to say something I just
kept looking down at his knee and then
looking at him and looking down at his
knee and then looking down hopefully to
like like hello he didn't even feel
weird that we were like rubbing legs and
we were rubbing legs on my chair on my
chair not on the shared space on my
chair
what have we learned
I don't know what have we learned say
something I
I'm just like nothing changes unless you
say something I know everyone thinks I'm
like so aggressive and confrontational
but I'm not she's not but you by the way
you were like if you don't say something
I'm gonna say something I'm gonna say
something let me switch seats and you
didn't say anything because I got him to
move I didn't need to say something at
that point I needed to say something
when you were sitting next to him and he
was taking up your space I actually took
a picture of our legs like and I was not
even being shy I was like being obvious
like taking a picture just to like show
proportionally how crazy it was what
[__] nerve like what hurts but you
think you have that you could sit on my
goddamn seat [__]
the Dutch
now I'm thinking he was definitely
German he was in Dutch he was definitely
German I don't even know if he was
German and the whole thing makes sense
why because it was anti-semitic I'm a
little Jews and he's just giving Third
Reich energy
um so yes Pete Davidson got into a fight
with a man who was definitely annoying
but um I feel like I'm telling you I
think Pete Davidson is in his bad boy
era
I love him
I have no problem two things can be true
I'm not having a problem I'm just saying
like he crashed a car into a residential
home while there was literally like a
teenager there and now he's starting
fights in public I'm telling you I think
something's going on with Pete Davidson
I think he's just living his life you
don't think something's going on with
Pete Davidson nope
I think so stop trying to tear down
funny men
excuse me because it sounds like you're
talking about yourself
we are torn down we oh you're in the
same category as Pete celebrity ah
celebrity who do you think is a bigger
celebrity me or Pete Ben Soffer or Pete
Davidson
it's tough it's tough it's tough I'm
gonna have to go
Pete it's tough just because he was on
SNL it's were there any other
celebrities here that I'm forgetting
about Lily James was really random
but remember when I took your glasses
and I was like I think I see a celebrity
Daniel Jones was there shout out Giants
you said picture Cruise
it was so cool
Ben Stiller and his wife you know they
like got divorced or they separated at
after many years of marriage and now
they're getting back together and they
really seem happy I was staring at them
the whole time and they were sitting
next to Sienna Miller and the guy that
she was with who was not famous crazy
neck pain do you ever have pain all the
time starts in your neck radiates to
your shoulder blade and then if you rub
out the knot in your neck your shoulder
blade pain goes away
to Pivot Claudia doesn't believe in
knots oh my God I don't not believe in
nothing I rub her back and there are
knots and she says stop moving my bone I
was like there's a difference between a
bone and a knot if you want me to rub
your back I'm rubbing out knots I'm not
here to not rub out knots right Ben will
rub my back which is so generous thank
you I love it I love you dearly and he
will quite literally take my shoulder
blade and like move my bones around and
it'll be like wow that's a big knot it
was I [__] not [__] it's my bone and
it feels so weird to have like your
bones and muscles like be moved it's not
a knot it's just my bones it's not a
knot it's just my bones
cool you ready for it for the final
only if it's the fifth and final that's
brought to you by Dreamland baby do you
know perchance if it is
I think it is Dreamland baby but how
would you know
I'm excited to learn about this
Dreamland baby we want to introduce you
to a product that over half a million
parents including Jax are using to help
their baby sleep the Dreamland baby
weighted sleep sacks and swaddles it
started with Tara a mom who couldn't get
her baby to sleep she was exhaustrated
exhausted frustrated and searching for
answers I mean we've all been there her
solution was to create a gently weighted
sleep sack that your baby can safely
wear to help them feel calm fall asleep
faster and stay asleep longer so it's an
award-winning doctor approved dream
weighted sleep sack and it is only sleep
sack that features cover com technology
it's evenly distributed weight from baby
shoulders to toes and it naturally
reduces stress allowing your little one
to relax and sleep soundly you know I
have experienced the power of a weighted
blanket many times and you know babies
are really like bundles of nerves
they're very anxious very scared they
miss their mommy and so using a weighted
sleep sack Jackie loves the Dreamland
ones she actually had Olivia ship her
her Dreamland baby sacks from her house
in Florida to here in New York while
she's in New York because she she needed
them
so if you have a baby that's having
difficulty falling asleep or staying
asleep rest assured this is a safe
effective product and you need it it's
gently weighted and they come in sleep
sacks and swaddles for newborns to 36
months it's created by a mom whose baby
was waking up every hour and a half and
the gentle weight mimics the feeling of
a parent's touch and hug the best news
is that they're offering an exclusive
discount to the toast listeners just
head to dreamlandbabyco.com Pages toast
and use code toast at checkout for 20
off and put your sleepless nights to
rest that's
dreamlandbabyco.com Pages toast and use
code toast all right I picked a fifth
and final story a little more sports
news but it's actually pretty funny so
the Lakers player D'Angelo Russell has
been forced to remove his drink from his
post game Podium interview did you see
this no so everyone's a walking
commercial these days but the NBA will
have none of it unless it's under their
terms after the Lakers beat the
Grizzlies in game three the guard
DeAngelo Russell went to the podium with
the hopes of promoting his new sports
drink during the interview but an NBA
employee employee likes stormed the
podium and was like that drink put it
down and D'Angelo Russell responded why
and she said it's not one of our
partners he said but it's my partner and
he said you're gonna have to find me and
then he held up the drink coco5 plugging
the brand the woman who works at the NBA
then walked over to Russell stand over
stood over him shook her head and
grabbed it
hmm who worse team are you on NBA or
D'Angelo Russell I mean it's giving me
in spirit Society I know I know you will
literally like put your drink anywhere
by the way as you should of course he
owns it right he's probably like an
investor or something but he and he's
he's excited about it and he has some
face time and it's a good opportunity
and it's a big game post game I have to
assume that they won they did post game
drinking it promoting its use like the
NBA like [__] that no I mean if the NBA
was smart yeah if they were smart what
they would do is they would say you can
do it but I want a piece yeah it kind of
has Shark Tank like every brand that
comes every brand that goes in an NBA
post game interview gets a little piece
yeah
because otherwise it's giving me Air
energy just pay the fine the fine is so
worth it it's so much cheaper by the way
we saw air did you and I talk about it
on the podcast we did are you sure I
thought so I feel like I spoke about it
with Jackie then I I mean I definitely
spoke about it on Good Guys it was so
good yeah like I loved it oh which by
the way good guys today oh yeah by the
way we'll talk about it but huge episode
today huge episode we could talk about
it okay but I want to get back to air
okay so what do you want to do super
quickly okay John Stamos is on good guys
today spoiler alert it was fantastic
yeah and Ben like got to chill it was
when you were in La so usually a lot of
the guests you're here in New York and
you're kind of like a third wheel yeah
totally but I was there you were there
you'll also see what reminded me of it
is uh Sports society's obviously
promoted every single episode of good
guys and both John and Josh are sober so
it was like a oh I didn't know John was
sober too yeah yeah that child after
life man I don't think John was a child
actor she was really young like no I
mean I think he was just in his 20s no
he was like really young
yeah but whatever that made me think of
it but
um back to air uh air is the new movie
produced and created by Ben Affleck and
Matt Damon about Michael Jordan and more
importantly about Michael Jordan's
contract with Nike you really don't ever
see Michael Jordan so if you're looking
to see Michael Jordan I wouldn't see air
no you're more like I went on the
podcast and gave like a whole diet tribe
about how stupid it was that he wasn't
Anna but if you're more of like a
marketer and you find the creation of
products and Deals interesting there's a
very interesting movie about a deal that
single-handedly shaped the way that
celebrities endorse products yeah uh
where Michael Jordan not only I got a
deal with Nike who at the time was at
the bottom of basketball shoe game but
his mom negotiated in a 10 royalty on
every Jordan was it 10 yeah they didn't
say in the movie what the percentage was
so what they did say though was that
Michael Jordan gets 400 million dollars
a year in recording royalties and I know
that the Air Jordan makes about four
billion dollars a year oh the next 10
that would be 10 percent
wait 400 million is 10 of 4 billion yes
I don't think that's right yes it is
wait
so 400 million times 10. it's 4 billion
yeah okay no you're right you're right
you're right yeah
um oh wait
no I'm telling you no
400 million
no it is it is it is you tricked me it
is sorry no no I was just being I was
confused but it is it is all right so I
guess 10 yeah I was curious what the
percentage was yeah
um but the coolest part was when they're
creating this shoe Claude if you
remember
the NBA had a rule where 90 of the shoe
needed to be white there could only be
10 color while you're wearing it while
you're wearing a shoe on the court
during a game they have to like abide by
their dress code and if you don't you
get fined they made the Jordan the Air
Jordan
far more than 90 percent white no far
less far less than 90 white it was all
red and they agreed to pay the fine
every game right and that is historic
marketing yeah no that was really smart
it's like basically paying it for a
commercial so cool right and so honestly
D'Angelo Russell out here as the press
conference came to a close Russell said
Coco five several more times and
naturally the promo ended up being the
best in companies history the video has
millions of Impressions has been viewed
more than 580 000 times as of Sunday
night and Russell is a partner in the
sports drink company along with Devin
Booker Derrick Rose and Charles Barkley
among others love Charles Barkley isn't
Derrick Rose on the Knicks yeah he
doesn't play anymore why he's just a
little bit over the hill and that's
what's so weird to me about sports like
which I'll never understand like how did
Tim Tebow go from being like the Wonder
kid of football to like not being able
to get a draft pick well Timothy does a
little bit different why football's a
little bit different why he just like he
was a great player no I know but to be
like in football his position is
quarterback you can't just like you
don't just like Sub in quarterbacks
randomly when they start to go over the
hill in basketball your point guard but
he wasn't over the hill he was literally
21. he was over the hill Tim Tebow he
just like was never even that great I
just that's what I don't understand he
was famous he's good and then bad
there's a difference between famous and
good okay that I understand he was
famous okay and he was fine okay Derrick
Rose was awesome had a terrible injury
never really recovered it's still really
solid he should get a little bit more
burn which in basketball talk is just
playing time oh thanks and uh but yeah
if you could play any sport
professionally what would you want to
play golf
Shadow will zalators got it I mean talk
about like something more boring no what
do you mean it's unbelievable it's so
boring to watch on TV no it's not it's
amazing it's really boring have you ever
been to like a golf um like watched like
a game like a televised you know what I
mean like a competition
do you mean have I ever been in person
watching golf yeah it's terrible yeah
yeah just because unless you're there
look if you're there as a golf fan
I don't I personally don't enjoy because
you don't get to watch all the holes you
get to like watch one if you're there
though as like a fan trying to get
[__] up and like enjoying oh yeah yeah
apparently I haven't been to waste
management I heard that is just a parte
parte but no I
um I love you I love you more great
episode great episode if you need more
Ben today there's a brand new episode of
Good Guys Ben's podcast that he host
with Josh Peck it's a toast News Network
show and their guest this week is John
Stamos what do you guys talk about John
I don't even remember we should talk
about his sobriety maybe a little bit we
spoke about a lot we spoke about a lot
oh that's helpful did you talk about
Full House yeah what does he say I don't
remember he guess he got to tune in
no no spoilers you know how important
promo is when it comes to Spritz when it
comes to your podcast I can't remember
no by the way go tune in it's amazing we
talk about Full House we talk about
Fuller house we talk about John Stamos
we talk about his lovers you talk about
Bob Saget at all we do talk about Bob
Saget because Josh and him were both
really close with Bob Saget well John in
particular is really close yeah so it's
a really great episode tune in and
Summer's approaching if you're low on
Sprint Society you can go to sports
society.com and use code toast for 10
off thank you guys so much
um Jackie is joining me this week for an
audio episode I'm not sure what day but
I've got a couple of great guests lined
up I don't want to spoil it but just
just stay tuned it's going to be a
fabulous week here at the toast thank
you all so much for being so patient
with us hope you have a great day thank
you so much for listening to the toaster
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories that you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're still
available